hey youtubers is Charlie so Daenerys
Targaryen shares a whole lot in common
with her predecessor Aegon the conquerer
they both had three dragons they're both
getting ready to conquer Westeros so I'm
gonna explain the history of Aegon
before he conquered the Seven Kingdoms
in how that went down there is a new
round of the game of Thrones giveaway
going on now all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on this video
be sure to click that Bell to enable
alerts so you don't miss out on anything
so the story of Aegon the Conqueror in
Daenerys Targaryen actually starts
before the doom of Valyria with Daenerys
his predecessor Dan is the dreamer from
who her name flows who had a vision of
the doom of Valyria about 12 years
before it happened so the head of the
Targaryen household at that time in our
Targaryen took his family all of their
holdings all of their dragons everything
in migrated to a Valyrian outpost that
was Dragonstone and made their home
there so twelve years later the doom of
Valyria happened in within about six
generations Aegon was born and ended up
being about eighty-seven years after the
doom of Valyria so during that time
after the doom of Valyria and during
Aegon's early childhood there was this
giant power vacuum left by the fall of
the Valyrian freehold so there were
constant Wars people vying for power the
rise of the free cities places like
slavers Bay as a child Aegon was
watching this all happen so the only
real conflict that he got involved in in
the east before he conquered Westeros
was as volantis was trying to expand its
territory so volantis here was attacking
Tyrone pentose trying to expand Aegon
Road balerion the black dread in support
of Pentos and Tyrone and basically
burned the opposing forces fleet before
it could attack just like Daenerys this
past season in episode 9 burned the
great masters fleet before it could
finish laying siege to marine so that
war with volantis was the last major
conflict that Aegon got involved in in
the east before the conquer of Westeros
after that he lost complete interest in
the east so in the years before the
conquest as Aegon was growing up he
visited Westeros a number of times with
his sisters he visited old town he
visited Lannisport he was guests of some
of the other lords so he spent a lot of
time in the kingdom he commissioned the
great table carved in the shape of
Westeros like the giant map table that
you saw in the first couple seasons of
the TV show he commissioned that long
before the conquest of the Seven
Kingdoms so at the time just like was
happening in the east just constant Wars
people vying for power the same thing
was happening in Westeros
the Starks ruled the north the Gardiners
not the Tyrells ruled the reach that
actually happened after the war of
conquest so we'll talk about that in a
second house Aran still ruled the Vale
the Martel's
still ruled down in Dorne but here in
the Riverlands and here in the
Stormlands there were two Lords named
Haran [ __ ] called harren the black and
our galactican they were two of the most
belligerent petty kings at the time in
Westeros in Haran [ __ ] of Harrenhal was
pushing down into the Stormlands
stealing territory from our galactic in
fear reached out to Aegon the conquerer
and said please support us help us get
rid of Harrenhal I'll promise you the
hand of marriage to my daughter but
because Aegon was already married to his
two sisters in order to cement the
alliance he offered the hand of his
closest friend and bastard half-brother
Horace Baratheon so if you guys didn't
know he was the first of the House of
Baratheon it was formed during the
conquest but Horace was sort of the John
snow of the family at the time he was a
Targaryen bastard so he was a Gon's
half-brother so he still had noble blood
in him but our Galacta hands of Aegon's
envoy just completely offended by the
idea that his daughter would marry a
bastard instead of marrying Aegon
himself so Aegon countered back that as
part of the dowry he would have to give
up a bunch of his land in what is now
the crown lands basically like a buffer
between the Stormlands in between the
river lands in the territory the Aran
[ __ ] controlled so our galactic wanted
to create this Targaryen buffer between
him in Haran [ __ ] so after our galactic
Aegon's offer of or espera thien's
marriage to cement the alliance and sent
the envoys hands back in a box seven
days
after deliberating on the matter Aegon
sent Ravens to all of the kings of
Westeros in the message read from this
day forth there would be but one king of
Westeros those who bend the knee to
Aegon of House Targaryen would keep
their lands and titles those who took up
arms against him would be thrown down
humbled in destroyed so a lot of you
know that the Iron Throne is made from
the melted swords of the people who did
not bend the knee to Aegon the conquerer
so like the Starks for instance bent the
knee meaning that their blades were not
melted down in the Iron Throne and this
is a picture of the actual Iron Throne
as it's meant to be not the one on the
TV show so it wasn't like he just melted
down the swords of the Fallen Lords it
was like the Lord's and all the people
under him there were thousands of swords
that were melted down to make this so a
lot of people was wonder are there
Valyrian swords that were melted down
that are in the Iron Throne no that is
not the case
Valyrian swords at that time were
extremely rare extremely precious just
like they are today they're more scarce
today but at that time they were still
pretty rare so most of those are just
regular steel swords but what happened
is is that initially during the conquest
Aegon did not have the most massive army
he gained support over time at the time
of the conquest there were seven kings
of Westeros Seven Kingdoms you get the
idea
torence Stark in the north Ronald Arryn
in the Vale Haren [ __ ] in the
Riverlands loren lannister
in the westerland's marin gardner king
of the reach are Galacta the storm lands
in Merriam Martell an 80 year old woman
who was ruling Doran at the time so of
those seven kings you notice that there
are three houses that aren't around
anymore
House whorehouse de randon in house
Gardner one of the first houses to fall
was Harrenhal they call it the burning
of Harrenhal which is why the stone
looks all melted there was a scene with
Arya during season two I think where
they get taken to the lannister
controlled Harrenhal Gendry and hot pie
wonder why the stones look all melted in
Arya replies dragons
what kind of fire melts time Jaqueline
fire dragon said nah we were dragons are
dead
what's that spell
dead people
OOP so the story of harrenhal itself the
castle is pretty ridiculous it was meant
to be this giant monstrosity to tower
over all other castles to show everyone
that Heron horror was the most mighty
king in Westeros so of course in
spectacular fashion Aegon melted most of
the tower so it still exists because we
visited it during the first couple of
seasons on the show but thereafter it
was said that the place was cursed in
each new Lord to hold the castle met an
untimely end
just terrible things would happen there
so you never want to be gifted with
Harrenhal it's always a great thing when
the king gives you a castle Harrenhal is
the only one that you do not want after
the conquest of the Riverlands he moved
down to the Stormlands and conquered our
Galax territory took it for himself
in gave it two or Spur a thean marrying
him to our Galax daughter creating house
Baratheon so that was the beginning of
the Baratheon's in the Stormlands so a
lot of you are wondering yes Gendry does
share a small amount of genetic material
with Daenerys they're like very very
very distant cousins next he conquered
the westerland's in the reach there was
a very famous encounter called the field
of fire whereby the gardeners had their
armies massed ready to fight in an open
field
Aegon rode his dragon it burned the
entire field tens of thousands of
soldiers to the ground and that was the
end of house gardener when he then went
to Highgarden the Tyrells had been
stewards of the castle they yielded it
immediately so Aegon named them house
Tyrell Lords of the reach later the
Starks knelt in submission so torrents
Stark the king at the time became known
as the King who knelt he conquered the
Vale and then finally Dorne was the last
place that he went but because of the
terrain and because his army wasn't used
to desert tactics he had to withdraw
thus it was really the six kingdoms that
he conquered and then many generations
later Dorne finally came into the fold
but Aegon did not conquer Dorne so a lot
of you are wondering are they going to
mirror this with Daenerys in season
seven as she goes after Cersei the
Kingdom will split some like the
Lannisters like house Tarly will support
the crown
others will support Daenerys at the idea
of a new Targaryen reign so just like
when Aegon first made landfall in
Westeros and started the conquest his
army got bigger over time as he gained
support so the same thing will probably
happen with Daenerys so I wouldn't be
surprised if Daenerys has a couple
encounters before she treats with House
Stark in they form an alliance but then
you have other houses like house Tyrell
that have already pledged their support
to Varys so it's not like Daenerys is
starting at zero she has her unsullied
she has the forces of Highgarden but
when you look at all the faces here at
Cersei is being crowned these aren't the
faces of really happy lords and ladies
so part of great drama is in watching
people who you would think support
Cersei completely turned against her
which I'll link my Jaime valonqar Theory
video at the end of this so let me know
in the comments do you think that
they're going to mirror Aegon's conquest
with Daenerys as season 7 plot as she
marches on the Iron Throne in which
houses do you think will bend the knee
inside with Daenerys if there are any
other history videos that you guys want
me to do just let me know in the
comments below I will say
congratulations to infinite mortal Gear
this week's giveaway winner please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details and there is a new round that
started with this video I'll just
announce the winner the next time I post
a Game of Thrones video
so next history video might be a history
of the Starks and how they came to be
wargs so if you guys want anything else
just let me know in the comments while
you guys wait for that to post you can
click here for my Jaime valonqar Theory
video and you can click here for my
Westworld season 2 predictions thank you
so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
you